[Musique]
lieu atypique singulier le centre d'art
contemporain d'amilly propose une
dizaine d'expositions par an la dernière
en date porte sur le thème de
l'interruption en référence à la crise
sanitaire
l'exposition éclectique fait appel à
tous les arts la vidéo la sculpture la
peinture la photographie analyse braille
est une artiste qui parcourt la
méditerranée à la recherche de traces
d'histoire qui sont pas forcément des
grandes traces d'histoire mais qui sont
des moments d'instantanés extrêmement
riche et varié où on voit la fragilité
finalement la perception des choses que
l'on a quand on est en voyage en
déplacement quand on regarde le monde
donc elle est très très belles choses ça
va des objets de natures mortes des
paysages des photos d'actualité ou au
contraire des photos d'un passé
prestigieux qui est celui de la
méditerranée
[Musique]
la richesse de la programmation des
tanneries leur vaut de recevoir après
seulement six ans d'existence le label
de centre d'art contemporain d'intérêt
national c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement important les premières
expositions qu'on a fait lorsqu'on
sollicite est de près d'eur il fallait
prendre beaucoup de temps et d'énergie
pour déjà nous présentez nous dire ce
qu'on allait faire comment on allait
envisager se développer tout ça
maintenant et à qui le label rend compte
d'une réalité dans le monde
professionnel auprès des artistes les
tanneries sont maintenant tout à fait
situer sur la carte
[Musique]
pour faire simple en fait aux tanneries
ce convoi on voit nulle part ailleurs
c'est cette singularité qui est reconnu
les tanneries sont le deuxième lieu de
diffusion d'art contemporain à être
reconnue d'intérêt national en centre
val de loire avec le ccc au des atours